>>> THAT AFTERPARTY ON SATURDAY
WAS WILD, HUH?
>> SUPER WILD.
THAT OPEN BAR GOT ME GOOD.
CAN'T HELP BUT HAVE A LITTLE
HANGXIETY.
>> ABOUT WHAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I WASN'T LIKE WEIRD TO ANYONE,
WAS I?
MICHAEL LONGFELLOW.
KISS ATTACK.
I WANT TO SEE THEM LONG FELLOWS.
>> DUDE!
STOP IT!
>> THAT'S JUST HANGXIETY, MAN.
IT'S ALWAYS WORSE IN YOUR HEAD
THAN WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
>> OKAY.
COOL.
JUST WOKE UP TO A LOT OF MISSED
CALLS.
NO BIG DEAL.
PROBABLY JUST HANGXIETY.
>> NOTHING TO BE NERVOUS ABOUT,
DUDE.
LIKE, MARK, ME AND YOU ARE FINE,
RIGHT?
WE'RE ALL GOOD?
>> YEAH.
WHY WOULDN'T WE BE?
>> GIVE ME MY PHONE BACK NOW!
>> OH, YOU WANT YOUR PHONE?
>> YEAH, GIVE ME MY PHONE BACK
NOW!
>> JUST MAKING SURE.
ALL GOOD.
>> MAN, HOW MUCH DID WE DRINK?
>> NOT MUCH.
I HAD LIKE TWO NEGRONIS AND
MAYBE LIKE 40 BEERS.
>> WHOEVER WAS BAR TENDING WAS
MAKING THEM STRONG.
>> DUDE, LET ME MAKE IT, YOU'RE
TOO SLOW.
>> I'M FILMING YOU.
>> GO AHEAD, FILM ME.
>> MAKE IT.
>> MAN, WHO ORDERED THE
MARGARINI?
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING.
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> ANA.
>> THAT PARTY WAS FUN ON
SATURDAY.
>> THANKS FOR COMING.
>> YOU WERE A DELIGHT.
>> AND WERE ME AND YOU KIND OF
VIBING?
>> SO LIKE ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
USUALLY IN SPANISH OR ENGLISH?
>> CAN YOU STOP LIKE YELLING IN
MY MOUTH?
>> YOU'RE HILARIOUS.
>> SERIOUSLY, YOU SMELL LIKE YOU
HAVE A DEAD TOOTH.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> COOL.
DIDN'T THINK SO EITHER.
BACK TO WORK.
>> WELL, ANA, EVERYONE LOVED
YOU.
SERIOUSLY, I WAS WITH PEOPLE ALL
NIGHT, AND ALL WE COULD TALK
ABOUT WAS HOW FUN YOU WERE
BEING.
NO!
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S JUST SO NICE TO SEE YOU
GUYS HOW YOU REALLY ARE LIKE A
FAMILY HERE.
♪ DON'T YOU FORGET ABOUT ME ♪
>> YOU NEED AUTO TUNE!
YOU NEED AUTO TUNE!
>> YOU'RE A JEALOUS BITCH!
>> LITERALLY THE POT CALLING THE
KETTLE BAD!
>> MY SHIRT!
>> FAMILY.
>> WE ARE.
>> TOTALLY.
>> HEY, GUYS.
OH, IT'S MESSY IN HERE.
THAT'S CRAZY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY YOUR BEHAVIOR
AT THE AFTERPARTY WAS UNACCEPT
LABLE.
>> SORRY, MIKEY.
>> THIS IS A WORK PLACE.
ACT LIKE IT.
>> OKAY, MAN.
GOD.